Hey everybody, this is Brent Dixon. I'm an assistant scout master with Troop 192 in St Cloud, Florida.
This edition of the Scout Master Podcast is very happily sponsored by backers like me.
Thanks, Clark.
And now it's the old scout master.
Everybody is going to be relieved to hear this news.
They finally found that scout over in the Austrian Alps who was lost.
It was a very, very long search because it turns out that that scout was hiding.
Okay, think about it. Austrian Alps scout hiding, lost, long search.
Classical music- That's a clue. The scout was hiding.
Oh man, Maybe we should just move on. There's nothing more to see here.
Hey, this is podcast number 305..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look at the mailbag.
A couple of podcasts back have played a story that scouter Mike Marty sent in about his senior patrol leader and a discussion he had with him,
And I got this reply from Patrick Garrett this week.
He said finding ways to better integrate scouts with special needs is a passion of mine,
So the story from Mike Marty was especially moving.
I'm really impressed with his senior patrol leader and how he asked for help and Mike's thoughtful approach.
The only thing I would say is, if your future stories are going to leave scouters all misty-eyed during their commute, you might want to warn them first.
Patrick, I'm glad that story meant something to you and I'm going to take the opportunity to tell everybody again.
You've got a story to tell Every scouter does,
And the reason that they're important is not because they're these like incredibly unusual things that happen.
It's because they're very common things that happen,
Because we all share the same kinds of challenges and achievements.
We all run into the same problems, We all have the same victories,
And sharing those is important, and sharing them in your voice, I think, is really important.
So this is what you do.
You can do this one of several ways. You can sit down on your computer and record a file and send it to me.
You can record your voice over your cell phone and send me that recording.
Or you can call a number and I'll have that number in the podcast notes
And you can just talk to me via the phone and that'll record it and we'll put it on the podcast
And it'll be interesting and inspiring for everybody else.
Like I said, you think, nah, it's just me.
Nah, that's not what it is. It's about scouting and what we're all doing.
You think, oh, I'm not going to sound very good.
Look, I don't really care for the sound of my own voice.
305 podcasts later, Still don't like listening to my recorded voice.
And you think, oh, I have to do it just perfectly, and I have to go back and do it.
No, you don't. If you knew, if you had any idea how much stuff I edited out of my podcast
and how many times I repeated myself before it sounded good enough for me to put it on the air.
Don't worry about it, I'm going to edit whatever you say to make you sound brilliant,
All right, And if you want me to, I will send you a copy of the edited recording
before I put it on the podcast.
So just you know. do that this week for me, okay.
Record a story from your experience as a scouter,
Send it to me and I'll put it on the next podcast.
Another thing that happened this week is, as I've talked about in the past, several podcasts
finally got the audiobook version of My Book- So Far, So Good-
a new Scoutmaster story- published
And it's available now at scoutmastercgcom.
It will also shortly be available for direct purchase on audiblecom and iTunes.
It just takes a little while for them, to you know, do whatever it is they do before it gets put up there.
And I heard from Kenneth Tillman about the book and he said
if I had this book to read when I started my troops six years ago,
we might have had more of the 50 or so Scouts who have cycled through still with us here in the troop
Right now. we're waiting on the next round of weeblos, ready to cross over,
with a few more activities planned that will show them what a great troop we're starting to be.
Thanks, Clark, for the words of encouragement.
I've started to use your mantra: so far, so good.
Thanks, Kenneth, So far, so good.
That's all we can hope for most of the time. right.
And Tom Tomlans also wrote in about the book, said
we went from adult lead to mostly youth lead.
They make decisions, The Scoutmasters advise and guide,
but they do what young Scouts do and learn from it.
Thank you for all your wisdom and thank you, Tom.
I really do appreciate that.
Every week, if we can manage it- and we did this past week-
we have a couple of live chat sessions at scoutmasterscgcom.
Watch the Twitter feed and the Facebook feed for announcements of when we'll be live,
usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings,
And a lot of our frequent fliers checked in on the chat this past week,
In addition to Eric from Georgia, who's a training chair,
and Dan Bennett from Redding California
and is the membership chair for their pack.
Both Eric and Dan were on the chat for their first time this week.
Stop in and say hello Tuesday and Wednesday morning.
scoutmasterscgcom.
Watch the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed. come
and join in one of our live chats.
If you're a regular listener to the Scoutmaster podcast
and you read what we have at scoutmasterscgcom-
and those things have helped you.
you can return the favor in a couple of different ways.
You can make a one-time payment
and become a scoutmasterscgcom backer,
or you can join the growing number of people who are choosing
to make a subscription payment via Patreon
by pledging $5 or more a month.
Now there are special premiums available to anyone who becomes a patron
or a backer. so to become a backer,
what you do is go to scoutmastercgcom,
click the support link at the top of the page
and you'll find a number of options there on how you can become a backer.
I want to take a moment to personally thank Jim Brockes,
who has become a backer since our last podcast.
To become a patron,
what you do is click the link to my Patreon page in the podcast notes
or go directly to wwwpatreoncom
and you'll find out all the details
of how all that works when you get there.
And I want to take a moment to personally thank Bill Blankowski
and Mark Van Loon, who have become patrons since last week's podcast.
In this week's podcast we're going to talk more about patrols
and the patrol method,
and I've got something special to share with you about that.
so let's get started, shall we?
I want to tell you about Richard Francis Thurman.
He was always known as John John Thurman.
He was born on the 4th of April 1911,
and passed away in 1985,
but he was the third camp chief at Gilwell Park in 1943.
He was only 32 years old when he became the camp chief at Gilwell Park in 1943,
and he remained in that position for 26 years.
He was the author of 15 books on scouting
and he made a considerable impact on world scouting,
and his influence lives on through his books
and through his work in wood badge training.
Now, one of my recurring themes here is that the more things change,
the more they remain the same,
or everything old is new again
because you know, after a century
there's not a whole lot we're going to run into in scouting
that hasn't been run into before.
Most of the difficulties and challenges that we encounter as scouters
are old ground. okay,
There's a lot of people who've already dealt with them and overcome them,
and I like to look back and to see how they did that,
because it's a way to form our own resolutions
to some of these difficulties
and a way to understand the really important basic ideas of scouting.
And one of those basic ideas is the patrol method,
and John Thurman wrote the Patrol Leaders Handbook in 1950.
So pay attention to that date for a moment. 1950,
the good old days when everything was great, right
And scouts were scouts and well you know, I'm going to tell you
They were encountering the same kind of challenges then.
None of this is new
and that makes what Thurman had to write timeless advice
that is meaningful for us.
It's easy to get a copy of most of his books in PDF format
and I'll link to resources about that in the podcast notes. okay,
But I want to read from his introduction to this Patrol Leaders Handbook,
because it is one of the better explanations of patrol method
that you're likely to encounter
and really get you into the spirit of what the patrol method is about.
So Thurman wrote:
the patrol system is made up of a lot of littles.
This is why there are difficulties about it
and why there are problems,
why it's not too easy to understand
and why I hope from this book
you'll get a real picture and a vision
of all that the patrol system can and should be mean and do.
I've always been glad it isn't too easy.
If all we had to do was write patrol system
over the entrance to every true headquarters
and sort of a miracle resulted,
it would really be too simple to bother with.
But fortunately- and I mean fortunately-
it isn't as easy as that.
It does not get any easier as years go by,
and perhaps in that lies its secret,
its charm and its possibilities.
It always needs, and always will need,
two special qualities:
the one common sense, the other effort.
I hope you have the first,
which is by no means as common as it should be,
and will make the second,
because upon these two things
the rest will depend.
I, and indeed many others, can explain a little,
suggest a lot, advise perhaps
and encourage always,
but no one except you, the patrol leader
can really do anything about the patrol system,
because it really does all depend upon you.
It is your show and it is always up to you.
When scouting was started,
the idea of the patrol system was really
a very revolutionary thing.
In fact, a lot of people criticized it
and told Baden Powell that it was dangerous,
that it would not work
and that he was asking for trouble
and that the boys would let him down.
Things have gone by.
the method of the patrol system
has carried far outside scouting.
In the early days of scouting,
boys from all over the country,
and later from all over the world,
bought the book Scouting for Boys
and formed themselves into patrols.
I want to repeat:
formed themselves.
This means that someone,
a leader not appointed by anyone in particular
but chosen by other fellows
because those same other fellows
were willing to follow him,
a crowd of chaps who wanted to be scouts.
They formed a patrol
and they started to train themselves
using the book Scouting for Boys
as the only guide.
But they found- as patrols have always found-
that there were many things they did not know,
many things they could not find out
and many things they could not do
without the help of some adult,
And so the practice grew
of a number of patrols getting together,
forming a troop and usually finding
their own scout master.
Sometime in the year 1908
that a gang of boys saved up their pennies
and managed to purchase two or three copies
of Scouting for Boys,
They met together in an old barn
and tried many of the things
that Baden Powell suggested they should do.
They had a lot of fun
and learned a great deal,
and they got into quite a few scrapes.
One day they came across the chapter on camping.
Now, as they had tried all the things suggested,
they were not going to be defeated
by one, which seemed a little more difficult.
Of course, none of them had ever been to camp
and they didn't know the first thing about it,
but they had a real spirit of adventure.
They were prepared to try anything,
not only once but until they got it right.
And so they talked it all over
and devised a manner of means
to get things they thought would be suitable.
Bill, Jack and Tom were to get the food,
just how nobody told them.
Martin, the leader, was going to get the tent,
and Alec the Youngest said
he thought he could get a cart.
The leader also said he would look after the cooking pots,
and each boy was made responsible
for getting his own bedding.
So it happened that one Saturday afternoon, early in June,
they duly assembled at the barn
and started out on their travels.
No questions were asked,
although young Alec did indicate
it had been very difficult to get the toy cart
away from his baby brother,
and Jack was not very complimentary
about the very old tarpaulin
that the patrol leader said was to be a tent.
but they were all amazed and delighted
at the quantity of food that had been produced,
which by present day standards
would have been enough for a month.
Well, they packed what they could into the cart,
and after the food was in there
there was not really much room for anything else,
so the rest was carried.
They did not know where they were going.
they had no map and I doubt
if they could have read one. in any case,
They set off literally into the blue,
out of the village and over the hill
in the west country, because
they were not the sort of fellows
who walked on roads if they could avoid them.
but all their preparations had taken a long time
and it was quite late in the evening
when they settled on a place to camp.
Pleasant enough campsite between a by-road
and a stream.
They decided the stream would do
for washing water and for cooking.
It was all very unhygienic,
but they did remain alive for many years.
to tell the tale,
They lit a fire, as they had already learned to do,
and used more than two matches,
and it was a very large fire.
They then set to
and cook the food.
They mixed some very queer concoctions
and they burned quite a lot,
but the food had never tasted better
to those particular boys.
Then, rather late, they tried to put up the tent.
The leader had a knife
and cut down two saplings and somehow,
with string and ingenuity,
they rigged up the tarpaulin into some sort of tent
and as it became very dark,
very tired but very happy,
they crept into the tent
and got into bed.
Fortunately, as they didn't know anything about ground sheets,
it was very dry.
They did not know that cold rises from the ground.
in fact they did not know very much at all,
but they were learning by doing.
They talked in the tent
feeling very much like pioneers
and gradually, one by one, dropped off to sleep,
all except the leader
who felt a special responsibility
and although he had not told the others,
he was going to try to keep awake,
Suddenly, in what seemed to him
to be in the middle of the night-
but was actually only 10 o'clock-
he heard footsteps, which stopped
outside the tent.
The leader kept very quiet until the light
of a torch shone
and he looked out to see a very large pair of boots.
As his eye traveled upwards,
he saw a pair of dark blue trousers
and, from somewhere
a very long way above,
a very deep voice said:
and what are you supposed to be doing?
The others woke
and there, to their dismay, was a policeman.
The leader said:
we are scouts and we're camping,
but in 1908 not many policemen
had heard about scouts,
and certainly this one hadn't.
and his answer was:
well, you are coming home now.
Very sorrowfully, the patrol
packed up their gear and went with the policemen.
They were very surprised to find
that they had not far to go
owing to having no map
and practically no sense of direction.
they had almost traveled
in a circle and were in fact
camping quite near home.
We will draw a veil over what happened
when they got to their various homes,
but they were not daunted,
as they had arranged to meet at their barn
the following night. The Sunday evening
found them together again in the barn,
and the leader had not been wasting his time.
He had reread
scouting for boys
and the first thing he said was:
look here, chaps.
I have been reading the book again
and it talks about a scout master.
I think that is what we want.
he would have kept the policemen away.
well, that is one of the jobs
of a scout master and it is one of the reasons
why your patrol or troop needs one,
somebody who will arrange
for you to carry out scouting
without fear of being erupted.
I do want you to remember
that this patrol started on its own.
they were out together and they came to realize
the kind of things that a scout master
can do for the patrol,
and they found a scout master for themselves.
that troop is still running,
perhaps because it started in the right spirit.
I suppose today it is usual
for the scout masters to form the patrol
and then the scouts to get on with it.
the important thing about the old method
was that right from the start
the patrol leader realized
he was really the key man in the whole business
and if he failed, then his patrol.
he did not lean on the scout master,
except for those things
where he was quite naturally lacking in knowledge
or ability and had to go to an adult
for help.
what I am afraid happens so often now
is that patrols are not really patrols at all,
but only used as convenient
divisions for a scout troop.
a scout troop ought to be a
meeting together of patrols.
if a patrol is only
a convenient division,
it is not a patrol at all.
a troop meeting ought to be a place
where patrols meet together
to compete against each other
and to encourage each other
and, having met and learned all they can,
should go away as patrols
to practice and get more experience.
unfortunately, what has happened in this country,
in many parts of the world,
is that the troop meets too often
and the patrol not enough.
I hope your patrol is going to be different,
that it is really going to meet
as a patrol, away from the troop,
without the scouters
going back to the scouters for advice and help.
the wise scout master knows
that this is his job, but sometimes
the patrol leader does not let the scout master
do his proper job
but will insist on leaning on him for everything.
I want to remind you of one of the things
that Baden Powell said about the patrol.
he said: expect a great deal
of your patrol leaders
and 9 times out of 10 they will play
up to your expectations.
but if you are always going to nurse them
to trust them to do things well,
you will never get them to do things
on their own initiative.
so that's just a part of
the introduction to John Thurman's
patrol leaders handbook,
and a lot of that sounds like it could be said today
and could have been said 10 years ago
and 20 and 30 and 40 years ago.
this is a recurring thing.
the whole patrol system idea is not easy
to get. remember what he said.
it's pretty difficult and it should be so
and he's thankful that it is.
patrols need to be not just
convenient subdivisions of troops
but actual vibrant
living things.
they are really the basis of scouting
and a lot of people get back to me when I talk like this
and they say: well, man, this is really frustrating
because boys just don't know
how to do this anymore.
well, they do. the problem is
is we don't have the confidence
to let them figure it out
and remember this is supposed to be
difficult, this is supposed to be
hard, this is supposed to be a challenge
and it's as challenging for scouts
as it is for adults.
this is as much of a foreign idea to them
as it is to you, but I find a lot
of encouragement in the idea
that 66 years ago,
when John Thurman wrote this,
he could have been writing it into answers to emails
that I receive all the time.
I leave you by repeating one of the first
things he said in this introduction,
and that is:
this patrol system takes two things:
common sense and effort.
it's not easy, although it can be
daunting, and it can be a little
confusing and difficult to see
the initiative happening sometimes.
use your common sense
and keep extending effort in that direction.
you're going to be happy and you'll
be rewarded by seeing the patrol
system grow. but of course
that is secondary to the
rewards your scouts will derive
from a really active and vibrant
application of the patrol system.
thanks for listening to this 305th
edition of the scout master
podcast. keeping in touch
is pretty easy to do. go to
scoutmastercgcom. you can read
over 1600 articles
that are there on the blog
and you can subscribe to receive updates
to new articles by email.
you can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom
in the vast panorama
of social media.
you can join 12,000 folks who like
scoutmaster blog on facebook.
tweet along with the chorus of 1500
tweeters on twitter. pin the
portrait in his pictures, proffered publicly
with 2,400 other prolific
penders. on pinterest. watch us at
youtube. but look
funky. if you can't face facebook,
if twitter makes you bitter, if you have
no interest in pinterest, you don't put
the you in youtube, don't worry about it.
zoom into the late 1990s
and fire off a good old fashioned email.
I'm available at clark
at scoutmastercgcom.
that's C-L-A-R-K-E
at
scoutmastercgcom.
now, if none of those ways
of getting in touch work, look around
your stately manner home and
you'll find a bust of shakespeare.
the bust is hinged at the neck
and there's a red button inside that bust
that will open a secret passageway.
so push the button, the passageway
will open. slide down the bat
pole in that passageway and I'll be
waiting for you in the batcave to answer
all your questions. by now it should
be abundantly clear that the scoutmaster
blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of anybody
in particular other than myself.
we are not endorsed or sponsored
by any scouting organization.
it's just me talking into a microphone,
trying to lend a hand to scoutleaders
and have a little bit of fun along the way.
and speaking of fun.
here he is again, our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone
you.